and a bill to increase baby access to
baby formula and provide more funding
for the fda is headed to the senate in a
mostly partisan vote all house democrats
and only 12 republicans voted for the
bill providing 28 million dollars to the
fda because they're pro starvers they're
not pro-lifers they don't like women
they hate women they hate babies they
hate children especially poor children
who have to have wic who needs snap who
need food stamps they [ __ ] hate
america they [ __ ] hate it there's a
recall on baby formula there's a factory
shut down the fda is working to get the
factory back open so that the formula is
safe for parents to give to their babies
got it the gqp ninka poop let's go
brandon nazis have been blaming joe
biden personally for the shortage last
night when they had the chance to make
sure that our government could do
something like they've been calling for
192 of them that's right
192 not five not three not a couple 192
voted for your baby to starve your child
your grandchild that neighbor down the
street the person who lives in the
couple floors above you voted for their
baby to
starve i'm sure it's because of radical
socialism radical social i mean we want
the government to make sure we want joe
biden and the government to make sure
that all babies have food in this
country but when it comes time for us to
actually govern and do policy and make
sure that the administration has the
relief funds to do what they can do to
make sure that all babies have their
formula [ __ ] you we don't actually
believe in this stuff that's what the
gqp is about you think these trump
pumping idiots who think jfk junior's
still alive who think he's gonna be the
vice president or is the president or
some [ __ ] you think these people are
gonna believe facts no [ __ ] no they're
not that's what th that's what the
republicans are counting on they're
counting on this these [ __ ] imbeciles
to believe their untruths their
misinformation their disinformation that
is the plan folks and the only way to
combat it is to use the ballot you you
pro-democracy voter i'm talking to you
your ballot is the weapon we can use to
stop this [ __ ] dumbing down of
america the simple fact that we have a
shortage of baby formula in this country
and we we can't even we can't even agree
that babies shouldn't starve no matter
what their color no matter where they
are no matter if they're citizens or
they're not or they're migrants we can't
even [ __ ] agree at this point because
of the dumbing of america that babies
who are in our country should not starve
the best news is is we have a democratic
house of representatives we have a
senate that is controlled by the
democrats we have a democratic president
do you think that if the republicans
controlled the house they would pass any
relief for baby formula [ __ ] no they'd
be yelling and screaming about it on all
their trader tv cable news networks and
then not doing a goddamn thing because
that's what they are they're [ __ ] do
nothings they're obstructionist they're
insurrectionist they're fascist let's go
brandon nazis 192 republicans voting to
starve [ __ ] infants oh well it's got
this in the bill and we just can't
stomach we just can't stomach poor
children getting nutrition in this
country my god we're gonna force women
to have those babies but those babies
should pull themselves up by their
[ __ ] bootstraps and get their own
goddamn formula because joe biden let's
go brandon nazis the gqp are pro
starvation after days and days and days
and days
and days of telling us how it's the
democrats fault that there's a formula
shortage and joe biden should do
something about it right now i don't
even need to show you the [ __ ] proof
i don't have to go through the tweets
marjorie taylor green lauren bobert
louie gohmert every last one of these
[ __ ] fascists matt gets all of them
every [ __ ] last one of them had a
tweet or some kind of statement about
how joe biden's making sure baby formula
doesn't get into infants mouths and the
minute they have the chance to actually
govern to do something they vote no [ __ ]
you but they've always voted no they
date decoupled food stamps from the
[ __ ] farm bill which is the [ __ ]
point of the goddamn farm bill that's
been the success of the farm bill for
the last century so if you want to doubt
me that they're pro starvers good luck
good luck to you
you